[Music]
after completing this lesson you'll be
able to explain the various types of
graphics available in our list of
possible file formats of graphic outputs
describe the methods to save graphics as
files and describe the procedure to
export graphs in our studio with its
large set of powerful functions our
defines a flexible graphical environment
for the visual representation of data
these graphics that help in meaningful
data visualization can be viewed on
screen and the users can create
precisely customized graphical output
the graphics can be saved in various
good quality formats including PDF PNG
jpg WMS and PS typically graphs are
designed on screen which can then be
repotted on for example a PDF file you
can also copy and paste in case of a
word or PowerPoint file using R you can
produce a variety of graphical images
basic 3d plots scatter plots bar plots
histograms box plots and pie charts our
eight standard statistical plots that
are can provide are can also support
heat maps word cloud kernel density
plots and line charts
let us look into details of each of
these graphics in the subsequent streams
plotted on vertical or horizontal bars
bar graphs show discrete comparisons
among a categorical data the lengths of
the bars each of which represents a
category indicates the frequency
percentage or proportion of values that
fall into the categories the syntax to
create a simple bar chart is bar plot X
in the function X stands for height
which is a matrix or vector if the
height parameter is a vector the values
of the vector give the heights of the
sequence of rectangular bars that make
up the plot let's look at a few examples
of how to create vertical and horizontal
bar charts here by using an embedded
data set of empty cars you can plot bar
graphs to create the first bar graph you
pass gear data to the bar plot function
the default setting for bar orientation
is vertical to plot a horizontal graph
you can pass horizontal equals true as
the second parameter to the bar plot
function in the next screen we'll take a
quick look at a few arguments to edit
simple bar plots you can add labels
colors and titles to the bar plot by
using specific arguments for example
legenda text is useful when the height
is a matrix the arguments X lab and y
lab provide the labels for the x axis
and y axis respectively call will define
the color of each bar by default if
height is a vector then grey is used
whereas if height is a matrix a gamma
corrected gray palette is used main sub
gives the overall and subtitles for the
bar plot this demo will show the steps
to create a bar chart in our
in this demo you'll learn how to create
bar charts
for this data we will use the empty cars
data set available in our
you
simple bar charts can be created using
the bar plot function
you can create horizontal bar
specifying a horizontal equals true as
an argument to the bar plot function
you can also add title color
debar plot by specifying details in an
argument
you
for more options or help document type
the given command in the console
you can create a stacked bar
plot if the input is a matrix the
stacked bar will indicate each column on
the matrix the argument beside specifies
if you want the bars to be stacked or
adjacent to each other by default the
side is set to false and if height is a
matrix a stacked bar graph results if
you set beside to true then you get the
columns of height as adjacent bars you
can create a stacked bar plot with
colors and legends as shown in the
screen here in this example on the
screen it's a matrix of vs and gear data
from mt Carr's data sets
using the same example as in the
previous screen you can create a grouped
bar plot reiterating if the height
parameter of bar plot function is a
matrix and the side is set to true then
the values in each column are juxtaposed
rather than stacked here you use the row
names function to set the legend which
will set or retrieve the names of rows
or columns of a matrix like object in
this demo we'll show the steps to create
a stacked bar plot and a grouped bar
plot in our
in this demo you'll learn how to create
a stack bar plot and a grouped bar plot
for this data
we'll use the empty cars data set
available in our
you
for a stacked bar plot and a grouped bar
plot will have to create a table like
data from the empty cars data set using
the table function you can create a
stacked bar plot using the bar plot
function you can also add title colors
and legends to bar plot by specifying
details in an argument
you can create a grouped bar plot by
specifying the side equals true as an
argument to the bar plot function
you
for more options or help document type
the given command in the console
pie chart is a type of graph in which a
circle is divided into sectors each
representing a proportion of the whole
pie charts are not as popular as dot
plots or bar charts and are you can
create pie charts using the function PI
X comma labels equals here X is a vector
of non-negative numerical quantities the
value of X indicates the area of a pie
slice labels are character strings or
expressions that give names to vectors
the example shown here you first create
the slices vector which contains numbers
10 12 4 16 and 8 lb LS is the labels
vector then you pass both these vectors
to the pie function as parameters to set
the overall title for the plot you pass
main as a parameter
in this screen you can see how
percentages can be added to the pie
chart in the given example out of the
data vector you can create the PCT
vector and the character vector lvls to
add actual labels to the slices to paste
data to the labels vector and add the
percentage sign you use the paste
function another character vector call
helps fill in or shade the pie slices
let's now see how you can create a
three-dimensional pie chart using the
plot tricks package which has the PI 3d
function you can produce 3d
representations of pie charts there is
an explode parameter that enables the
pieces to be separated on the chart
however you first have to install the
plot ryx package and reference it using
the library function install that
packages Patrick's library plot rigs
this demo will show the steps to create
a pie chart in our
in this demo you'll learn how to create
pie charts
pie chart graphics are not available by
default you'll have to install the plot
tricks package by using the given
command after installing you'll have to
load the package into our using the
given command
for this demo we'll create a custom data
set using vectors we can create pie
charts using the PI function and the
plot tricks package we can also add a
title and labels by specifying the
details in an argument
you
you can create 3d pie charts using the
PI 3d function and the Patrick's package
you
for more options or help document type
the given command in the console
let's look at another visual
representation of data distribution the
histogram histograms are a great way to
get to know your data a histogram has an
x-axis a y-axis and bars of different
heights the bars group ranges of values
or continuous categories on the x axis
and the y axis shows how frequently the
values on the x axis occur in the data
they display the distribution of a
continuous variable and the frequency of
scores in each bin on the y axis by
dividing the range of scores into bins
on the x axis as shown on the screen
the syntax for a histogram is hist in
our for a given set of data values the
generic function hist works out a
histogram if plot equals true plot
histogram plots the resulting object of
class histogram before it's returned you
can create a histogram using the hist X
function where X is a vector of values
for which you want to plot the histogram
instead of frequencies the option
frequency equals false plots probability
density when you want a histogram of
proportion to control the number of bins
that is VARs use the breaks equals
controls option the break argument helps
you control the bin width along with the
number of breakpoints you desire and the
example shown on the screen you can see
histograms for dark green color two bins
that indicate the miles per gallon or
mpg value of the empty cars data set a
more effective way of visualizing
numeric variable distribution kernel
density plots are created using the plot
density X function as shown on the
screen here X is a density object you
can use the density function to compute
the density parameter and plot
in the example shown in this slide you
can create a kernel density graph for
the mileage per gallon or mpg of empty
cars data set by first calculating its
density and then creating the graph and
the second figure used a polygon
function for kernel density of the data
for MPG vertices are given an X and
colors of the area and the border are
given by color equals sky-blue and
border equals black respectively
this demo will show the steps to create
a histogram and density plot in our
in this demo you'll learn how to create
histograms and a density plot
you
for this demo we'll use the Mt
data set available in our the histograms
can be created using the hist
you can also specify the number of Bin's
and the color of bin as arguments to the
histone
you
for the density graph we'll have
to calculate the density of
using the density function and then use
the density data to plot the density
graph using the plot function
you
you can color the curve representing
density using the polygon function
you
for more options or help document types
of given commands in the console
represent a series of data points called
markers connected by a straight line
this type of graphical visualization is
typically used to display data that
changes over time as shown on the screen
the syntax for a line chart is lines X Y
type equals for x and y are coordinates
of the points type indicates the type of
plot to be drawn say L for line and P
for points or B for both
now look at an example of a line chart
and the code shown in this slide you can
create weight and month's vectors and
then fought a line and points graph
together by calling the plot function
these two vectors are passed as
parameters along with main to set the
title of the graph as baby weight chart
also known as whisker diagrams box plots
display the distribution of data that is
based on the five number summary minimum
smallest value in the data set first
quartile 25th percentile median 50th
percentile third quartile 75th
percentile maximum largest value in the
data sent and data is broken into four
quartiles in box and whisker plots and
each quartile has the same number of
data values although these plots do not
display the frequency they show where
the middle of the data is a feature that
is really useful if you want to analyze
the skewness of your data the syntax to
create a box plot is shown on the screen
box plot data
a box can be created either for
individual variables or for variables by
group as shown on the screen the syntax
is boxplot X data equals where X is a
formula and data equals denotes the data
frame providing the data to make the
widths of the box plot proportional to
the square roots of the number of
observations in the sample use their
width equals true with horizontal equals
true you can reverse the orientation of
the axis default false means the box
plots are vertical in the code shown
here a vector of numbers was created and
the summary function called to print the
values of the following variables
minimum first quartile median main third
quartile maximum then the box plot
function was used to display the box
plot for the vector of numbers this demo
will show the steps to create line
graphs and a box plot in our
in this demo you'll learn how to create
line graphs and the box plot
for this demo we'll create custom data
set using vectors we'll use the plot
function to create line graphs
you
points in a line graph can be connected
by specifying type equals B as an
argument in the plot function
you
we can create boxplot using the boxplot
function
you
for more options or help document type
the given commands in the console
heat maps are two-dimensional
representations of data in which the
values are represented by colors the two
types of heat maps are simple and
elaborate heat maps a simple heat map
provides an immediate visual summary of
information an elaborate heat map allows
you to understand complex data sets rows
and columns can be clustered in a heat
map and the result of the hierarchical
clustering computation is shown as a
dendrogram in the heat map as shown on
the screen the syntax to create a heat
map is heat map data row v equals n a
column V equals n a here row B and
column V decide if and how row and
column zdenda grams should be calculated
or reordered data refers to the matrix
of values that have to be plotted let's
look at an example that shows you how to
create a heat map in the code shown here
you can create a data frame by reading
data from a CSV file and converting it
to a data frame before passing it to the
heat map function besides data row V and
column V as not applicable color as 256
and scale as columns to plot a heat map
graph are passed to the heat map
function
steps to create a heat map in our
in this demo you'll learn how to create
a heat map
for this demo you'll use the custom data
set imported from a CSV file
you
a heat map can be constructed using the
heat map function you can also specify
the color and scale details as arguments
to the heat map function
you
for more options or help document type
the given command in the console
also known as tag clouds or text clouds
word clouds highlight the most commonly
cited words in a text using a quick
visualization creating a word cloud in R
is relatively simple using a text mining
package TM and word cloud generator
package word cloud as shown on the
screen
to create a word cloud use a syntax word
cloud words equal data frequency equals
frequency mndot frequency equals two etc
you need to install the word cloud
package into the our environment using
the install packages word count and
library word count commands in the
example on this screen text data is read
from a CSV file and the word count graph
is plotted using the word count function
passwords frequency mndot frequency s2
max words as 100 and random order as
false the minimum dot frequency argument
specifies the minimum frequency below
which words that have a frequency lower
than that value will not be plotted the
maximum number of words to be plotted
are determined by the max words argument
random order means that the word will be
plotted in a random order if false the
words are plotted in decreasing
frequency
we'll show the steps to create a word
cloud in our
in this demo you'll learn how to create
a word cloud word cloud graphics are not
available by default you'll have to
install the word cloud package using the
given command and then load the package
using the other command for this demo
we'll use the custom data imported from
the CSV file
you
we can use the word cloud function
create a word cloud we can also specify
the minimum frequency and maximum word
as arguments to the word cloud function
you
for more options and help document type
the given command in the console
look at the various file formats for
saving your plots our supports several
graphic formats and runs on different
operating systems consequently there are
many formats to choose from depending on
what you want to do with the graph how
you connect remotely or locally and what
operating system you use a few of the
available formats are as follows JPEG
doesn't resize and it can be used
anywhere PDF easily resizable and is the
best choice with PDF latex P&G doesn't
resize and can be used anywhere
wmf easily resizable and works on
windows only best choice with word
postscript easily resizable and is the
best choice with OpenOffice and latex
slide you can see an example to save a
graphic output as a file regardless of
the way you connect or the type of
operating system you use the general
method that will work on any computer
that has our involves the following
steps select the file format you want
for example if you want to save your
plot as a JPEG file use the jpg driver
which only requires the name of the file
that you will use to save the graph note
that your plot will be stored relative
to the current directory which can be
found by typing get WD at the our prompt
entering your plotting commands next
we'll save those to a file then is the
dev ops command to close the file either
you will get a partial plot or nothing
in case you fail to enter the dev off
command after you are done with the
plotting commands so if you want to save
a JPEG file called my plot JPEG
containing a bar graph you will type the
commands as shown on the screen
recalling the example from the previous
screen you will see that you need to
re-enter the command to save your plot
to a file after making a plot to the
screen however in our there is another
command dev copy which will copy the
contents of the graph window to a file
without the hassle of re-entering the
commands and this approach produced a
graph as you usually do and then call
dev copy along with the arguments that
are appropriate to the driver for
example to create a my plot jpg file
from a graph shown by our type the
commands shown on the screen until you
call dev dev the plot isn't actually
written to the file
this demo will show this
to save graphics to a file in our
in this demo you'll learn how to save
graphics to a file you can save a
graphic as a JPEG file using the JPEG
function
you
you'll also have to use the dev dot
return the control to the console back
again
for more options and help document type
the given command in the console
in this screen let's see how you can
export graphs in our studio follow these
steps to export graphs in our studio a
powerful interface for our and the
graphics panel of our studio click the
plots tab click the explore menu and
select the save as image menu item the
save image window is displayed select
the image format and directory to save
the file click the Save button
follow these steps to export drafts as
PDFs in our studio in the graphics panel
of our studio click the export menu and
select the save as PDF menu item select
the directory to save the file click the
Save button
this demo will show the state
save graphics using our studio
in this demo you'll learn how to save
graphics using our studio
you
you can save a graphic from our studio
by clicking the export menu and
selecting save as image
select the directory to save the file
and then click Save
you
let's summarize the topics covered in
this lesson are includes powerful
packages of graphics that help in data
visualization bar chart pie chart
histogram kernel density plot line chart
box plot heat map word cloud you can
save the outputs of graphics in various
file formats such as PDF PNG and JPEG
you can export graphs in our studio by
using the graphics panel hey want to
become an expert in Big Data then
subscribe to the simply learned Channel
and click here to watch more such videos
centered up and get certified in Big
Data click here